what stops me is me playing the blame
game all my life what stops me is me
keep saying well I'm black they white
well that's you're not going to go
forward doing that what stops me is
saying I didn't have the opportunities
they have that's going to keep you from
going there if you can get past the
and say all right these are
real issues but the biggest issue is the
belief of myself the biggest issue is I
need to spend more time reading and
researching than partying I need to
spend more time reading and researching
than chasing women I need to spend more
time reading research and then you know
trying to go hang out being on Netflix
all day playing a game all day I need to
SP more time developing a skill set as I
evolve as I learn how the game is being
played as I get exposure to the game my
confidence builds up